[Musique]
bonjour à tous alors désolé je suis un
peu en retard j'ai un peu des prêts mais
qu avec mon business mais du coup je
suis là et on regarde des parties de
speed chelsea mu donc donc pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas je suis maître
international simon 7-6 le cern et je
vais commenter les matchs de speechless
aujourd'hui donc bonjour à tous et voilà
donc ça c'est la partie dont qu'ils ont
déjà fait pas mal
malheureusement je suis un peu en retard
donc je n'ai pas pu suivre suivre mais
voilà donc la con vous voyez baby sarah
a déjà gagné une partie est un biais
conneries qu'on n'a pas encore été bon
donc là la partie s'avère assez assez
visa qu'il ya un gros avantage pour les
plans parce que ceux achetés devait
avoir des gros soucis
je pense qu'une tour peut-être aller sur
la colonne râches venir faire des petits
soucis se racheter
peut-être même dame g5 ici ça me permet
ça me paraît pas mal parce que sur et
apprises en 2 4 il devrait y avoir tout
produit peut-être d'un prend est alors
d'un machisme
à ce moment là mais elle n'a pas joué
donc ok oui donc m6 je pense que c'est
un bon coup ça permet de bloquer un peu
la position
ouais j'ai quatre c'est berner ses deux
cherché à ouvrir la pollution est aussi
il faut noter que 1 guy n'a que six
secondes
donc ça va être un peu difficile oui j
étais génération jamin sa terre assez
récent d'ailleurs cette interview le cam
ayant octroyé à l'avant peu on peut on a
un peu peur la règle et blanc mais ça
devrait aller avec tout autour des 3 ça
devrait bien se passer mais c'est pas si
clair parce que peut-être que la prison
g5y nos rythmes ans avoir dû prendre au
jeu j'aime pas particulièrement et la
position des blancs
surtout que le temps de 126 oui mais bon
avec ce concept c'est très compliqué de
7 de son côté aussi
tout ça
ouais c'est compliqué la 4d g3 sagan il
a peut-être la dame g3 ou loi bon bah là
réussie qu'elle est bonne partie de sa
part donc ici je pensais peut-être g3 en
fait on la sait pas c'est déjà un
directeur à la prochaine mais j'ai trois
je pense que ça a gagné la dame bref je
vérifie après ça m'a l'air d'être pas
mal
donc ça c'est une position assise
symétrique très symétriques d'ailleurs
va pas parce qu on sait qu a fait ça qui
fait la différence
mais bon ça pas une très grande
différence fond après dessins que ça
devrait être à ça pas très fins et très
peu des synapses à cette position
non il ya un lien un plongeon qui
peuvent peut-être seulement des quatre
qui peut le protéger avec avec eux trois
plus tard peut-être qu'à laisser 3 suivi
de voeux 3 à d'autres ça doit être pas
mal
donc allez réfléchir benoît s'est
longtemps demandé qu'elle connaît pas
donc peut-être même car ça peut jouer
d'ailleurs le 4 mai après faut faire
gaffe parce que le pion des cas soit pas
soit batailles auxquelles a joué donc je
suis je pense qu'elle va se faire flouer
3 mai sur fond ou 3 il y avait qu à
payer ses cadres donc voilà dessins que
ça pas mal
salut et le gâchis et oui c'est la
première fois que je fais un instrument
france adhère donc oui ces colosses
école d or il va très bien on en profite
c'est le début de l'été c'est bien on va
dans arrêt tout comment ça se passe en
france en sont
ok donc la position s'ouvre il devrait y
avoir des pipes menace lui comme la tour
des emplois qualifiés 3 celui de caïds
et simple peut-être qu'à et b5 même faux
sites web car ça peut être un man vous
créez des menaces sur la dame mais bon
c'est pas encore très très clairs
d'amérique donc je pense qu'elle connaît
pas ce que tu as mis huit ça a l'air
d'être en coût qui n'est pas très
affaibli n'est pas très naturel donc si
elle vous ça surtout aussi vite
elle doit connaître ouais et ça c'est ça
ça a l'air pas mal en fait tu pourras
pour bibi sarah de faire un retour ces
huit peut-être ensuite la dame en c2
souvent devrait être vraiment des gros
problèmes en tête des cahiers des
quartiers peuvent arriver et des f-5
aussi peut-être seulement métal
ok c'est paul a donc parise ici aussi en
géorgie le déconfinement arriva
progressivement
donc c'est un j'ai déjà un peu à ce que
c'est que ça soit tous fini mais ça
arriverait bientôt j'espère ouais donc
elle a bien réussi à développer ces
pièces je pense que la coalition noir et
asseyez idéal papa la tour et fluide qui
fait pas grand chose mais s'ils arrivent
à allier ont dit oui ça pourra est pas
mal mais mangala d'amour entre et peu
partait peut pas sauter au dessus de la
dame donc la tour eiffel restera là pour
moi mais bon à part ça à toutes les
pièces sont pas mal peut-être même f5 ça
serait possible même en f5 c'est quand
même super affaiblissons affaiblissant y
aura peut-être des caves et j'ai gardé
g5 dans le futur en cas faut faire un
peu attention à chaque fois qu'il ya des
coups comme ça mais je pense que le jeu
des noirs ça sera plutôt lll d'amérique
desquels et bekaert ouais comme elle l'a
fait ou alors peut-être gagné 6,4 aussi
qui peut arriver mais des cavs a hissé
car suivi de calais prend b2 dépendantes
fume deux commandes adversaire joue
parce qu'il y aura des menaces sur le
cahier c3 avec carrick se fout là la
tour donc avec elle et ses quatre
salaires pas mal ça va être difficile de
défendre
alors des tournois n'ont rien de prévu
de tout surtout que là j'ai aujourd'hui
ils ont annoncé que le choix de france
aurait annulé donc voilà j'avais dit
petit espoir d'y aller mais mais du coup
ça se fera pas beaucoup non je n'aurais
pas tournoi à part peut-être le top 12
féminin ça sera juste en week end a donc
je crois que ces quatre ou cinq matches
en tout donc ça ça je vais venir en
france pour le faire donc ça sera pas
mal mais bon ça sera pas en vrai un vrai
gros tour
et toi alors et voilà les observateurs
est-ce que vous avez des tournois prévus
parce que y'a la coopama en europe
c'est ensuite je vais pas sur exactement
goût et dans les pays de l'est comme il
y en a plein le croit mais bon c'est
compliqué d'y aller sais-tu faut pas me
prendre l'avion et tout et les avions en
cette période sans que c'est un peu la
galère
donc voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai vite
on peut franchement là peut-être à trois
je réfléchis à ce coup mais à trois mais
surprise on reprend après le cavi repart
mais ça met pas mal ce à trois en fait
peut-être que je me trompe totalement m
ok donc la jouer de sa range donc bien
sûr car ici trois sets pas une menace
façon on reprendra surtout au point il
ya d'un point mais quatre donc ça c'est
jamais possible donc eu cinq son idée
c'est de prendre bessette
mais bon la table mais pas trop fait pas
tant bien à l'arrêt fait pas grand chose
là c'est pour ça que j'aimerais bien
faire un coup comme à troyes plus tard
et essayer de libérer sa position un peu
fouillis sion 2 mp non ils ont annulé à
cause un frein à cause de la situation
c'était difficile de faillite
aujourd'hui impossible c'était difficile
de trouver une ville qui pouvaient
l'organiser donc c'est sympa et ça pas
étonnant vu en que le fut le chaos le
chaos que c'est non
donc c'est ça ouais c'est pas sûr je m'y
attendais un peu d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
vraiment fait de plans pour venir ou le
mans j'avais quand même des petits
espoirs
donc là peut-être à 302 m'a l'air
vraiment pas mal pour chasser ce cavalli
après pouces et une baie 4 donc là si
elle arrive à faire ça donc dit sa
position se libérer un peu
elle aura même des idées belle menottes
peut-être mais bon ça sera quand même
difficile pas ce cas rien ces trois
mètres attaqué par la toux faudra
qu'elle passe en peu de temps a libéré
sa dame ça sera pas si évident que ça
mais bon faut vraiment qu'elle l'attend
donc là c'est au nord de jouer donc le
coût est rédigé quatre enfants ben et
bizarre mais j'imagine qu'elle voulait
empêcher fou mais fouet 5 mais ce n'est
pas vraiment une menace parce que on va
reprendre avec lecavalier
donc j'ai 4 ça n'a pas vraiment
d'intérêt importante mais bon j'imagine
qu'elle veut pousser mais bon c'est vrai
cambistes s'attendent surtout avec 47
secondes à la pendule mais bon c'est un
pont qui fit il n'a pas vraiment
d'intérêt je pense en tout cas pendant
ce mois peut-être qu'après ça et voulait
pouvoir échanger lecavalier sans avoir
peur de foule g5 toutefois être simple
peut-être je pense que ça doit être ça
son mandat donc ouais ok donc là
repartir donc elle veut garder les
places sont normal parce qu'aussi elle
prend le fou va être super actif et il y
aura des gros soucis sur sa diagonale
102 aussi le sou le flou s'échange
savait-elle donc elle a choisi de garder
le cavalier ce qui est normal doit
peut-être b4 plus tard
plus piora troyat cahier pétrole alors
oui mais non il y avait 3 mais rouge en
parler c'était c'est à quel moment
c'était c'était ici voilà un peu plus
tard ouais voilà même ici il ya à ce
moment là il n'ya pas cahier pétrole est
aussi ici voilà donc ici non plus il ya
pas qu elle aimait trop parce qu'on va
reprendre avec notre cabane est aussi on
attaque ce qu'avait ya un mais quatre
donc voila c'était à ce moment là donc
ok tour donc elle a réussi à occuper la
di la colonne c'est bien chartres a
organisé la somme en tournant oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais c'est de cet
abandon au tournoi de 2000 personnes
c'était un tournoi d'une vingtaine
maximum donc c'est vrai que c'est quand
même beaucoup plus simplement vide donc
mais c'est vrai qu'ils auraient pu faire
au tournoi avec sommes en national 1
masculin national féminin avec liam a
way avec les lieux où les lots au niveau
10 ans ça aurait été pas mal ça aurait
été évité ça aurait évité d'abord livré
dès 2000 joueurs qui qui participent
aussi
mais mme dupouy ils n'ont pas fait bas
ce sont vous le gardez là la même
ambiance de championnat que d'habitude
ce qui est normal puisqu'ils assez
compréhensible parce que c'est avec les
amateurs faut pas une qui vaut donc ok
donc là peut-être car et détroit voilà
mes cahiers des trois y avait sa valeur
pendant un long feu cahier pétrole a
calé des trois saveurs de créer des
vêtements des grosses menaces sur tours
deux ans peut-être
ouais ok ok sur tours bien s'arrêter au
bon moment ouais mais surtour d'air ni
label où il y avait tout retour f3 je
crois peut-être qui vit tout vent on
aime attaquer cahier 4 ok bon je parle
je veux qu'on se concentre sur la partie
alors je visais que jamais en fait le
titre de maître de grands maîtres
imminent ça j'ai jamais vraiment envie
je vise le titre de maître d'un salon ou
alors grand maître d'un mixte donc voilà
le titre de m m de grands maîtres
imminent ça m'a jamais vraiment
intéressé c'est pas trés c'est pas très
fin il ya plus que ça dit bien mieux que
ça donc voilà donc là les blancs de le
faire j'imagine des trucs comme ça alors
on est le cas veille ici peut-être alors
il faut prendre un tank
mais bon c'est pas top et ça c'est pas
top
je pense que c'est carrément gagnant
pour moi surtout là il va prendre
elle va prendre et après pendant neuf en
f2 voilà c'est tout oui oui je visais le
titre de amy est peut-être j'aime plus
tard agassi
mais le rouge à lèvres être un peu
compliqué mais bon je vais essayer le en
fait j'étais tellement proches de 92 et
me jeter sa chute à deux doigts de la
mort mais deux fois mais bon du coup
j'ai seulement eu mètres de nous mêmes
normes de mettre un teint de m de grands
médecins
j'ai tellement pris l'habitude de parler
français d'ailleurs parce que là chaque
fois le lâcher en géorgie lui je parle
jamais française ou donc si je dis
nantes c'est pas de ma faute ok donc ne
me ne me rendais pas not it the way le
type de wii jeu de double vie jm c'est
pas mal mais bon ça c'est pas mon but
c'est vrai que c'est pas mal mais c'est
pas envie ok donc elles appellent à
annuler par la partie c'est bizarre ça
enfin si c'est annulé donc pour le mans
bibi ça va à deux points oui rampi en
point donc
mais bon c'est bizarre là ce qui se
passe je sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé
ils ont juste annulé la partie
ah c'est l'heure de la pause au congrès
well ont l'air sérieuses toutes les deux
elles sont elles sont elles sont
focalisés ce normal la bulgarie guéorgui
voix il va viser le titre de gm y plus
tard mais en mai pour le mans il est
plutôt coach banquiers se concentre là
dessus ils seront tous là dessus pour le
monde mais mais oui plus tard il va
essayer de devenir j'aime ça c'est sûr
bon bah du coup ils ont fait une petite
pause je sais pas quand il va en prendre
en attendant on peut être regarder les
parties précédentes
j'ai pas envie de perdre ça parce que
leur viguier avec ma technique
informatique je pense pas que ça mettra
une très bonne idée de l'auteur
donc j'ai pas envie de perdre cette
partie là ok bah du coup on va faire une
petite pause alors en attendant qu'ils
reprennent donc je vais mettre les
commentaires ni le commercial ça donc je
reviens au site
[Musique]
bon bah du coup ils ont toujours pas
repris mais bon on va les attendre
vous n'êtes pas très bas aujourd'hui à
parler parler d'un chat
alors quels sont vos pronostics alors
sur ce match entre entre bibi sa fnb et
oui une limonade oui oui mais c'est en
fait il sait pas ce qu'il y'a une pause
là ils n'ont pas repris les parties donc
j'attends mais je sais pas exactement
quand ils vont reprendre sa salle fauci
heureusement on attend
donc pour les informations ça
ici par exemple
le premier match c'est entre monts à 10
entre bibi sahara est limpide donc salée
miro sept numéros q3 donc voilà vous
pouvez voir ce qui va se passer et là il
ya beaucoup d'autres masques donc
sasasmit je crois que cette début début
juillet donc il y aura beaucoup beaucoup
de matchs quasiment donc ces trois jours
de suite je crois après il ya des pauses
il ya des pauses de quatre jours et
après ça reprend encore 3 jours de suite
donc c'est comme ça le planning les
formats c'est ça voilà donc vous avez
tous les infos là tous les infos sont là
et voilà
et ça c'est les appareils
voilà donc en attend toujours parce que
link grosse pause à non petites îles
vous repris ah oui ils ont repris
finalement hockey au petit lancy en
deuxiéme coup donc dame g4 ok donc le
début on va juste se reprendre un peu
c'est comme ça ok donc synonyme de vos
cartes c'est bizarre j'avais jamais de
sarah bon mais bon j'imagine que ça doit
être une prépa parce qu'ils me laissent
un meeting surtout joué sata vont
rapidement
c'est sûr que ça me ferait pas donc ok
ça va donc elle attaque le cabaye il
attaque le pion g7 donc sur l'accueil
pranger 3 il y aura bien sûr d'un proche
de 7
il y aura des brousses aussi pour les
noirs donc voilà déjà j'ai du mal à voir
comment les noirs continuent ici ça a
l'air très difficile ok donc l adoption
après la dame va
si j'avais peut-être ça après le pouvoir
va l'iran de cinq peut être aussi
cavalier le 3 suivi de camaïeu ça ou
alors dame ou avoir foulé trois choses
du genre jacques oussama mieux dormir
bras on peut ok donc est de poids n'a
vraiment alors que ce recours comme ça
ça montre ici c'est sympa ça me paraît
pas très naturel non plus donc j'imagine
que ça fait tous partie de sa prépa donc
alors madame 1,3 après j'imagine va
faire des trucs comme ça
donc là qu'avec le chien ce cas pas
moins qu'on a pas ce goût donc bon ce
coup il y fait un peu peur mais je pense
il fait pas grand chose devrait y
aborder d'un me 47 fois lors d'un mach
iii même d'albestroff tout simplement
suivi de foot est roi ça a l'air d'être
pas mal pour les boys
ans
aujourd'hui lorsque vous voyez c'est un
g2 les deux les deux différents un ouais
c'est amélie sarah les deux donc il faut
que je change ça attendez ça un peu
bizarre si l'on ne se passait
ah ok voilà en novembre
et oui parlera pas de france hélas oui
mais ça aurait été bien de voir avec
peut-être mari surtout qu'elle a le
niveau de deux jours mais bon peut-être
qui est basé son oncle
allez olla être pour abellan même c'est
possible ou alors dame de deux roues
j'imagine que ouais ok ils n'ont qu'à
venir
donc je pense qu'à le pousser h3 ou
alors peut-être des cinq le temps
bassila niveau mais bon il a pas dit
qu'il n'a pas de 1500 non plus donc là
c'est là par exemple comme l'icône
rousse et là je sais pas qu'elle doit
avoir de 1550 donc moi non plus j'ai pas
niveau pour jouer bien sûr alors que ben
ari c'est celle à 2500 et doit voir
qu'on s'engage contre 2 mai 510 un truc
du genre
donc elle pouvait vraiment être
sélectionné
peut-être fou des fonds tard c'est ce
qu'elle prépare
donc ça ça m'a l'air poteau points noirs
surtout aulas le roi il peut être assez
assez assez faible mais bon ce roi là
s'ils essaient de faire petit rock ça va
bien se passer pour lui donc
donc là j'imagine que le meilleur
pendant dix ans ça sera de faire une
grande rock suivi de coups comme cavani
mais trois peut-être ouais donc on sait
ce qu'elle appelle ouais parce que le
petit rock c'était c'était vraiment
horrible
surtout avec le avec le chang'e 2 way
peut-être cela on peut même faire j'ai
quatre
alors ça c'est une bonne question en
fait la plupart des compétitrices les
principales ont été invités mais il ya
aussi eu un toit avant donc y avait un
tournoi qualificatif donc les huit
premières des huit tournois
qualificatifs ont été invités aussi mais
voilà donc je crois que c'est ça s'est
passé il ya deux semaines environ il ya
deux semaines il y avait 1 8 tournois
justement qualificative c'était du blitz
était dure rapide c'était fin du blitz
30 minutes depuis cinq minutes et du
budget ou quoi c'était ça et voilà et il
ya huit personnes qui ont réussi à se
qualifier grâce à ça et mais bon y'a pas
que huit personnes en tournant ecomouv
comme vous le savez donc le reste a été
on était juste invité voilà
donc là juste pour le saas est donc
celle qui ont gagné je crois que je
crois que daisy corps il a gagné mais
après je suis pas sûr donc je vais pas
dire je veux pas dire un fenêtre d'un
homme 6 s'est qualifié en gagnant mais
je suis pas sûr je suis vraiment pas
suivre donc
mais voilà ça c'est toutes les joueuses
entoure
donc là ça m'a l'air est ce que sur la
prise il y aura la reprise et après tout
c'est un peu être suivi de deux fous et
5 être tours 7
je trouvais ça plus tard je pense que ça
devrait être pas mal tactiquement je
pense que c'est mon semaine perdant sur
la surprise ok donc ça c est ça sent
mauvais sens bon coup je pense
les favorites alors je sais pas si j'ai
fait c'est j'ai une image pour ça je
cherchais
voilà j'ai pas eu ma france a du coup
faudrait que je cherche même les
favorites
je sais pas trop je pense qu'aucun
billet de tracer favorite parce qu'elle
est vraiment elle a un très bon alors
mais à part ça le sait pas exactement
vraiment temps à chaque recharge et
ouais donc pour yifan clairement s
abritent parce qu'elle ré doit avoir de
1600 quelque chose du genre donc free
fight clairement valentina wind est
banal aussi na na na na aussi bon et
surtout très très forte donc on peut pas
vraiment dire
ouais donc là il n'y a pas grand chose à
faire
donc me sarah vraiment al'avantage 3 3
contre 1 7l vous bien
donc ça sur mon vélo non seulement avec
heures avec destination way point car ça
peut jouer par exemple ou alors même qu
à bf3 je pense
voilà donc deux positions c'est un peu
ouverte avec les changes les pions donc
là j'imagine que le plan des moments ça
sera un truc comme ça avec tous les
quatre et ankara 2 à 6 alors ça sera
agathe ou alors même mais des choses des
manoeuvres comme ça cavaliers des deux
c4
donc ça ça c'est typique j'imagine la
juste dans ses deux adorables foi c'est
le chat c'est le cavaly ensuite après
pour pousser le 4
donc là faut prendre des six on dirait
que le pion les emprises mais il ne
l'est pas parce qu'il ya avec la vanille
m6 qui attaquera le faut avec la dame
donc après le fousseret objet de
repartir vers prieuré qu'il prend des 5
et le pion c3 aura vraiment des gros son
donc là le cas ça m'a l'air pas mal
à assise de suite oui c'est ce qui se
passe en général jouant ici à 6 pour
pousser bezeq mais bon sur sade et blanc
répond toujours avec à 4 et du coup la
menace et on peut y a un peu bloquée
donc ce qu'elle a joué avec b si je
pense que c'est un peu mieux ça lui
permet de se développer un peu de
menacer des choses comme il faut à 6
donc nous allons voir si c'est pas si
donc oui c'est ce cas là le choisissent
donc c'est pour ça je pense que ça va un
peu mieux que assez ainsi un peu plus
dynamique
disons
ces quatre ok donc elle a choisi le
faire avant que son adversaire d'un jour
parce que son adversaire elle a fait
tourner un ici pour pouvoir faire ces
quatre au prochain coup parce qu'avant
il faudrait par le faire parce que la
tour était loin et et un sur la même
diagonale que le foot c'est s était pas
possible de faire ces quatre à son
endroit c'est pourquoi d'abord et là je
mets ça et après vous voulez menacé ça
un milieu polydor pour empêcher donc
tour 2 donc j'imagine son idée cette
fièvre des choses comme ça mais il y
aura sûrement mais pourquoi - comme
cavalier c'est simple de cavani des
trois salaires pas mal je pense que ça
devait assez ça doit empêcher la menace
de deux tours tours 1 sur l'accueil des
3 et après ça sera bien sûr pas possible
de pousser les pions parce que la tour
sera atteint
donc bon elle n'a pas joué donc elle
veut vraiment fixé la case de 5 même
poussé g5 peut-être
donc la nasa
ça a l'air vraiment à double tranchant
de cette pétition parce que c'est le
champion axis est vraiment très faible
affaiblissons ça vraiment ça donne
vraiment la cote de 6 donc ça aurait été
mieux pour elles n'ont pas joué ce coût
est de faire cavalier 3 on peut un peu
avant parce que maintenant on a une
phase aussi c'est vraiment très peu à
peu façon à l'occuper
donc ici un coup comme karim et si ça
serait quand même et même dans certains
cas reprendre le fil g7 mais bon je
pense que le cas il ya aussi ça sera un
monstre donc mon mieux le garder
dams est je pense que ça me paraît assez
assez probable j'appris ok c'est super
bizarre femmes elle a sacrifié alors
qu'il est donc elle pensait vraiment que
c'est un monstre à paris ce cavalier
donc elle a pris au caire et après fait
loi suit donc mon l'annapolis monde des
brins de gazon gamin je pense me reste
plus qu'à pousser des points alors vers
des choses je joue un fou des 4 et après
peut-être passé la dame faire ça a
peut-être et après on est là dans on h
théâtre voilà pas nous-mêmes f4 f5
peut-être
ah mince alors faut croiser les doigts
pour une bière
elle a aussi sacrifié savait pas ce qui
se passe dans cette partie donc là on
tout comme comme quoi j'ai deux ça monte
ça me paraissait simplement d'empêcher
toutes les menaces je vois pas ce qu'une
noire que ça ici mais bon elle a choisi
de redonner à tout le sahel à la guide
donc là j'imagine faire des trucs comme
d'hab messin peut-être et après essayer
de me montrer là enfin c'est ce qu'elle
a joués
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il
avait l'air assez dangereux mais bon je
pense pas que ça valait le coup de
perdre la tour pour ça surtout que là il
reste pas beaucoup de temps 17 secondes
ça va être difficile de ginza
même s'ils écoutent la commission
clarens gagnante mais avec le temps qui
lui reste surtout penser qu'eric elle
avec l'arena itar tass est ce assez
régulière ça va être compliqué mais bon
je pense qu'elle devrait réussir quand
même
donc l'adversaire commence à descendre
autant celle des super nouvelle pour
arabi
donc madame son roi dont bien sûr la
crise ça ne marche pas parce qu'on
reprend avec le roi affronte le pion
donc ici la technique pour gagner je
pense que ça s'est juste de pousser les
pions mais aussi coupé le roi sait très
bien pourtant c'est bel et bien sûr plus
tard poussé les gens donc peut-être que
la finale deux tours série gagnante si
l'échangé fait avoir des 4 et le 5 mais
bon c'est un peu un peu risqué de vie de
faire ça sans savoir
mais bon ça m'a l'air gagnent un peu de
progrès après + a privé faire un rodez 4
est évoqué si elle s'y est là étant de
faire de 500 sont apprises bien sûr
voici les faits hk que des syndicats
pressés mais sa tour en acier ça de vrai
donc ça répète les mots mais en pire il
veut gagner
waouh même avec quatre secondes à lui
gagné ça me frappe c'est incroyable
c'est une grosse prise de risque mais
bon ça aurait été vraiment elle doit
grande île obligé de gagner les coeurs
en points contre répond 3 elle est
obligée donc c'est bien il se bat pour h
tour 17 d'être après prendre le cuir à 7
rieu reste plus qu'à prendre le pion le
champ b6
elle est réussie c'est bien bel esprit
de prendre combatif à mens pas merci de
me le dire
azuki c'est gentil en effet tu as raison
il y avait deux films il faut activer sa
vraie j'espère que c'est mieux
maintenant
maxime il est passif est maximisée sûr
je sais pas je pense que sur blé stream
il doit y être
donc tu peux aller le voir sur ressorts
bitstream si tu veux na ont regardé les
échecs féminin regarde le speech
bon là prennent leur temps toutes les
deux sont tout sauf sous les noix en
fait sa vie ça va la jouer très vite en
qui prend son temps
donc la tête faire des jets 3 infligé
deux autres même moustiquaires x3 il
fabrique
mais bon j'ai trois fous j'ai deux ça
m'a l'air pas mal
oui c'est ce qu'elle a joué au hockey
donc ça a l'air pas mal
donc là si les noirs font en fondant
rock c'est papin c'est un cerisier film
parce que le foot se retrouve à sion
longueur aux grandes diagonales qui
organisera le pion vsat donc y aura pas
mal guidé genre tam bessengue peut-être
ou alors simplement simplement à faire
des choses comme tireur qui a pris
pousser les jo finale dames
donc là je pense que c'est obligatoire
de pousser des 4 sinon c'est trop ça
aide vraiment trois tours
ti rock celui de f4 mais c'est dangereux
il ya toujours des fous h h3 fougasse
concentre sur les droits sur la dame sur
moi ou alors faire dh 3 peut-être mais
vraiment ça va être compliqué puisque
aussitôt qu'elle fait petit rock your à
foix iii donc je pense qu'elle doit voir
plutôt faire le manque ça a pas l'air
tôt pour un peu
donc ça mais fléchir donc nos clients
encore une fois est très mal autant ça
leur arrive souvent pour prennent
malheureusement c'est ça cuit le coude
vraiment ces partis se retrouvent
toujours aux i'm not alors qu'elle a dit
qu ils sont normalement avec le temps
c'est pas possible
donc elle a choisi groc
je tente rien même des des fous g4
l'armement
je pense qu'elle arrivera ce défendre
assez facilement avec vous et f3
peut-être ou alors d'amener 3e non pas
d'un être enfouis un fiasco prend bien
et simplement fou et je pense
le stream bugs
oui est-ce que c'est pareil pour tout le
monde ou alors est ce qu'il ya vraiment
des moureilles mon bus train sur le
stream
ok donc là et met la pression sur neuf
sur la colonne mais parce que sur d'un
point y avait fauché carte c'est bon ça
obligé de reprendre avec le avec le cube
et c'est vraiment poignant fallait bien
sûr on aurait bien aimé reprendre à
l'isle adam mais cela vaut aussi la pose
de fous j'ai quatre bons plats et se
défend comme elle peut maintenant c'est
pas évident
ta main savoir ma du coup je sais pas
trop quoi faire
c'est parce que les enjeux stream en
même temps sur twitch et aussi sur
youtube ont peut-être que c'est ça qui
pose les délais je ne sais pas trop quoi
faire dans ce cas la maman salah
donc dites moi si ça va mieux ou alors
si ça si c'est pas mieux alors
j'arrêterai le sais mais je le referai
mais en ce sens le faire aussi sur
youtube je le ferai je sors twitch comme
ça hop techno ça changera quelque chose
qui est donc eu qu'à se rend beau c'est
bien qu'il ait réussi à ce jour ouvrir
le centre on peut ça permet de se
libérer donc sur la prise donc la
paperie je pense elle a trouvé un
meilleur poupe parce que bien sûr c'est
pas possible de prendre à cause de dames
de tour prend l'air ça serait terrible
et sur cinq il n'y a pas trop de nas
donc vu que la prise n'est toujours pas
possible emplacement là je pense y aura
ercis ce qui va vraiment cosider
comprennent
mon du coup dites moi si ça aussi ça bug
toujours parce que si ça bug où
j'arrêterai le stream et je referai mais
elle sans passer par youtube comme ça il
y aura il y aura moins de bugs pour
mandela
ça peut plus ok super super ok merci de
me dire parce que tu fous là je fais
perd un peu ok donc sur re5 - elle a
joué quand même sur m6 c'est assez
dangereux pour les bons parce que on a
dit c'est pas possible de prendre le
faut à cause de tout reprendre
jérôme godefroy
alors
ok souffle parce que c'était écrit
qu'elle avait joué cinq mecs le temps
des blanton et encore c'est un peu
bizarre
bon là c'est redevenu normal donc il a
joué mais bon il lui reste pas beaucoup
de temps cet arrêt pour elle trente
secondes ça va être difficile surtout
hockey en général à des problèmes avec
le temps mais bon pour les points mais
bon si ça c'est pas ta font que ça
brille ça va c'est quasiment de même
niveau mais non
qui donne prend qu en essonne à quel
moment ce thème fion le 5 à tu veux dire
ici
du coup à 6,6 est parti mais est franc
et voilà c'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait et là je pense qu'il y en ait un
bel avantage pour lier pour les noirs et
les traits la place deux des trois
affiches aux autres mmo n'y a pas
vraiment de ce2 selon lui il faut donc
qu'ils avaient vraiment la partie
peut-être points ouais ça devrait gagner
un elle a gagné
ok les revenus donc la c3 3 pas mal ça
en match à 6 1 6 1 fut intense
jade et j'avais des pubs souffrent des
petits soucis avec mon ou vieillesse
menacèrent de sarrebourg de pouvoir les
caméras c'est ça que j'étais en train de
faire saluer de mal au hockey du coup
ils ont refait une partie donc la
séparation est indienne donc vous
connaissez bien les plans pour les
blancs 7 pouces cela il est plein pour
les north de pousser à aller droit
donc si l'ouverture à ces tactiques en
général c'est très c'est très agressif
surtout de la part des nord mais aussi
parfois de la part des blancs qui
n'arrive à pousser les pions ça peut
être assez dangereuse
donc la demande à deux ça leur en main
peut-être aussi bekaert suivi de 7,5
ouais donc la f4 et l'acide et renvoie
aussi aussi à la loi même nom nord aussi
ils le sont tous évoqués
donc je dirais que c'est peut-être dans
la faveur des blancs parce que s'ils
prennent là comme en vrai comme j'avais
dire s'ils reprennent ya le vrai michael
fiaux watches donc je pense que c'est un
avantage pour les mains surtout s'il
arrive à pousser
sylvain qui arrive à pousser voilà ça
reste ça fait un peu peur 27 pouces est
possédée 6
y'en a marre de monrovia chaque fois ça
fait il fait non je veux c'est de
remettre les caméras en commun
cette fois ce sera la bonne
voilà ok
ok seulement ça s'efface arriver
enfin je crois j'espère
calme et ça a l'air assez assez bien
pour les ancêtres attaque ils à tours et
le faux ça l'a pas mal donc là le seul
truc à regarder ce qui se passe sur faut
prendre à deux
mais bon je pense que ça doit aller vous
prend 1,2 à la limite on peut juste
sacré bientôt frk les c3
donc bien sûr un prix ça serait pas un
très bon échange pour les blancs parce
qu'après le curage 3 sera très faible et
aussi on aura par deux notes ou une
autre flanquée de cette passe c'est pas
top
donc là je pense que ça serait mieux de
jeux de mots jeux la dame et après
d'essayer de faire j'ai quatre
donc le temps de lens est pas top comme
dame donc ouais mais bon la police en
aurait été pas mal mais là ça là on
dirait qu'elle a perdu son pion avant
c'était bien parce que la veille tuant
des six salades et menace pas la
reprendre bientôt
c'est pas très convaincu bourses et
l'arrivée à mettre la pression sur le
cavaly noyer même là le roi si les
partis c'est très difficile
deux mois à venir même si la paire de
fou avec ans la carrière formes en 2d
même même sens le temps ça serait un peu
difficile nous avons là il faut prendre
à ses tout premiers sets ça peut être
intéressant qui le font revient
peut-être y aura des menaces ou alors
même l'un des cas pays des cinq
peut-être well as perdu votants
n'accepte prévisible
donc là je pourrais tu es une pause je
suis pas sûr manger attendre de mars
l'espace
je pense qu'il ya une petite pause il ya
une pause mais la pose du coup un rabbin
je vais vous mettre le petit peu et je
serai bientôt je reviens battant hockey
[Musique]
sa reprise donc là ils ont sciemment à
l'ouverture mais voilà c'est comme ça
que ça se passe donc si nous perdions
pas bizarre d'ailleurs surtout ici
prendre avec le avec le cavalier je vais
pas me sera très régulièrement je pense
que normalement s'il faut prendre avec
le client donc pourquoi on prend avec le
puant après on essaie de sortir le fou
prendrait que cavalier c'est un sens
bizarre mais j'imagine qu'elle doive et
doit être réparé ça doit être ça
sa prépa donc ça ressemble un peu à une
brune fine sauf que normalement il dans
les montagnes aurait déjà le club en
justice
bon ça s'est passé comme ça
donc on l'habille sahara et gagner quand
même une partie donc elle mène et
bagarres et la dernière partie mois
qu'elles ont joué donc elle mène un peu
mais robbie est là et c'est la remontée
besoin moment elle avait été lavé perdez
3 1
et là maintenant c'est assez serré donc
tout peut arriver encore
donc là j'imagine qu'elle voudra faire
des trucs comme re5 mais il faut faire
gaffe comment faire sans doute parce que
ça laisse aussi le four des noirs
respirer un peu plus donc ouais tout
récent obligatoire ou non si gaby d2 ça
sera pas au top lors à défier trois
peut-être plus tard la sueur pas
maintenant qu'il ya tour aussi peut-être
de la faim a du mal à voir ce que la
tour fait un mode de faire effet être
mais moi je pense pas que ça soit son
idée de le faire et surtout ef car ce
serait pas forcément très bien ça
prendra du temps de le faire quelques
faut faire safari 4 et même une fois
grand père car c'est pas ses patins
j'imagine que la de plus tout jouer sur
au centre tête romney sa tour en dix ans
essaie de bouger ses débuts manqués au
port
donc 4 400 coups un peu mes dents pour
les blancs s'attaquent à des menaces ni
grossman race d'âge a donc là si on veut
défendre on doit faire cailler d2 mais
dans ce cas là il y aura peut-être fool
to b 4 4 qui attaquent le cavaly après
la menace sur 4 restera toujours donc
peut-être là pour faire j'ai trois pour
défendre mais on n'a vraiment pas envie
de faire ce qu'on voyait surtout que
c'est super affaiblissent ans ça laisse
le four ou des noix être super fort sur
sa diagonale
donc ouais en coups comme g3 je pense
qu'il faut jouer c'est obligatoire
vraiment ça nous fait mal de jouer ça on
n'y a pas eu trop le choix ici parce que
même sur tours est il y aura toujours
faux b4 à moins de fausser le 5 mai de 5
je pense que c'est encore pire parce que
le roi des fous première 3a loire ou
alors même d'un quart des 5 sa très
faible le clan des quatre ou six rappels
il y aura beaucoup de problèmes
pendant qu'est ce que vous en pensez les
pièces qui va gagner le match entre albi
et libye ça va
ok donc elle a bien fait g3 et après ok
je vais très vite dame g4
donc là j'ai l'impression que ça peut
être un peu donc dites moi si je suis
encore live là c'est ça marche encore
hockey qui est simple c'est bienvenu
celui en veut parce que bien sûr la
tournée pan n'est pas en crise parce que
il y avait la dame qui était inverse
donc il est obligé de prendre après tout
reprendre et peut-être quelques
survivants peuvent c'est très difficile
mais quand même ce fou de foot est roi
c'est à sarrebourg s'il faut prendre il
ya tout reprendre après il y aura tout
retour ces 8es elle d'illégaux autres
menaces peut-être aussi fou à 6 bref ce
sous la houle lala à la grosse gaffe la
mince alors elle commence à craquer
pas de pot n'at elle peut encore se
battre
oui mais bon c'est un peu difficile
surtout contrôler quand on nous remettra
ça papa c'est de gagner sa règle ou
alors même de faire annuler sa taille
qu'elle m'en tape f3 et a préféré fuir
ou à des trous pour laisser de
survivants
si on va du coup c'est parti quasiment
fini déjà elle continue à se battre et
la famille de perdre mais mes enfants ni
quoi votre là surtout que le plan on va
avancer aussi il va pousser la dame
ça va être très compliqué tout ça on lui
les magasins donc point guy 4 4
pas mal pas mal
ah mince alors est-ce que ça lag
ok donc la destruction des quatre ça
peut être normal mais c'est un peu
difficile à jouer pour les blancs parce
que là les noirs dans le centre qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire décaler ses six
états d'âme c'est celui de saint lô
peut-être ça a l'air assez facile à
jouer pour les noirs l'avantagé blanc
c'est qu'ils en se fiant kétou double
fier en ghetto mais c'est difficile
d'utiliser comme surtout couleurs le cul
en d4 commence à être plus dangereux sur
e3 le kg on peut même pousser jusqu'à
des trois noms certains pas ou alors
juste faire des trucs comme calisesi
sait garder l'option des 4 il va
reprendre
donc bon là c'est assez typique pour les
blancs de faire des 4 9 ans dans cette
position là je pense que becca sera lé
pou donc là bien sûr si noir reprennent
le pion des cats sera seraient perdus
donc ça serait une bonne chose pour info
les bains bien sûr donc sur b4 voyez
donc elle n'a joué donc probablement oui
je veux aussi dire que sur les 6 ça sera
très mauvais pour les noirs pas à cause
de la diagonale
donc il y aura des cailloux 5 par
exemple ou alors même des cailloux pour
gagner donc mais si c'était pas possible
et garde le pion c'est simple c'est pas
très dramatique pour les noirs parce que
ils arriveront toujours et a alors gagné
avec l idée ça tu es 7 5
donc la baie saint-jean - ouais c'est
assez logique donc avait chassé le
cavalier après forcer le cabinet dans
une mauvaise case sur bêtise comme on la
lit ça vous la diagonale en plus
d'inclure à des idées pour les blancs
après est ce cavalier à 5 fait vraiment
rien
donc ça ça rit ça peut aussi donner un
peu de contre jeu pour les bains
donc peut-être dix cavaliers g500 8,4
mais même une fois qu'il arrive en 4 il
pourrait se faire chasser par le
parlement ça ne devrait pas vous le cas
donc à gustou fermé veut fermer tout la
position donc j'imagine que plus tard il
faudra même essayé de faire f 4 après
les simples peut-être pour fermer un peu
plus mais bon je dirais que l'avantagé
quand même pour les noirs parce que ça
sera beaucoup plus facile pour les ors
du crillon contre joue avec un ep 5
surtout que là il peut être plus a ainsi
facilement former remettre son cavalier
de ce côté là ou alors même l'échangé
c'est encore mieux mais bon elle a
décidé de le remettre
ok j'ai sûrement elle voulait pas ouvrir
la colonne race et pour ça je veux la
prendre
ça va assez bien de prendre le mot
d'échangés le mauvais cabanier le
cabinet ans maintenant
donc là peuvent faire sans
énorme les grosses menaces les bleus
aussi cela va pousser s'il arrive à
pousser f4 et f5 c'est vraiment beaucoup
plus opulent dangereux que ça parce que
c'est là il va prendre le qui ont des 4
ça sera donc très problématique
ok donc là c'est pas mal des petites
idées soient légales donc là j'imagine
que le meilleur ça serait de prendre
peut-être et de sa écriviez 7,7 ou parce
que ça ne sera pas vraiment où en gros
sacrifices parce que dans que après ça
hop je peux pas je ne peux pas jouer au
hockey
je pense qu'elle a joué ça ma partie
alors je veux pas jouer trouve donc je
suis obligé de de faire les flèches donc
sur ça peut-être cavaillé aussi d'amuser
et sur la prise en effet huit les noirs
pendant l 3 tab
donc ça peut être assez intéressant
oh là ok oui oui donc sur ça et après
sur enfin ok oui donc sérieusement ce
que j'avais dit et après prendra chute
pas seule le problème c'est que le faux
est aussi attaquée et wau il lui reste
cinq secondes
je ne sais pas trop ce que pourra faire
et que cinq secondes de ça sera un peu
difficile pour elle on a et cabaye et g7
sa salaires de tout bloquer camélia cinq
qualifiés 3 peut-être
voilà je pense qu'il ya déjà que vos
avantages pour les problèmes parce que
deux pièces contre la tour c'est en
général pas un bon signe pour la
personne qui a acquis à la tour où la
calle trop peut-être
ouais ben dis donc on va avec avec en
fout du moment ça sera difficile
même quand on veut se battre
elle a perdu donc ben ça va mène avec 5
x 24
donc il joue toujours le même genre de
pays sont à chaque pas toujours avec un
centre de dents des côtes et enfin
général sein des fois les noirs qui ont
le centre et les blancs font des trucs
de fou b2 foule g2 est là si les noirs
qu'elle sert avec le fou le foulfouldé 7
et les bancs prennent le centre donc ça
c'est intéressant de voir les mêmes les
mêmes types de deux structures à chaque
fois
entre
ok donc la léonie et blanc sont obligés
de remettre le font parce que bien sûr
en trois ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens on
l'a dit donc l'oreille
en général il ya des petites idées comme
comme tous les ans pour occuper la
lincoln c on a vu dans les parties
précédentes
ou alors vous même dans certains cas
poussés des cinq voix lors de cinq donc
y aura des grandes idées dans le centre
ok ça a l'air pas mal donc sûr qu'il ya
des saintes
il devrait y avoir des palmes quatre
points connaissez pas sûr que ça marche
parce que je pense que cave il va
peut-être revenir en lice pour contrôler
la case achète et si la dame se pare
vent h4 il y aura à ce moment là faut
prendre trois c'est pas si simple
mais bon je pense que ça devrait marcher
quand même ouais ben ouais ça devrait
marcher donc c'est ce qu'elle a joué
donc après il peut aller se cacher en f4
peut-être sur tf6
mais ça leur dangereux pour leur super
dangereux
bon là il ya la menace bien sur l'eau
obligé de se cacher à schwyz
bon ça marche pas peut-être f 5500
terrible parce que ça fait oui le pion
qu'elle a bien choisi le roi donc là
j'imagine qu'elle veut et qui avaient
préparé des fous prendra six plus tard
celui de tours de cartes qui vit de
tours et j'ai 4 si ce qui peut être
assez dangereux donc là je pense que le
nord devait être assise assez précis
pour empêcher autour regarde surtout
donc je pense qu'il faut faire un truc
du genre kbc 3 pour ouvrir la diagonale
du fou ou alors et 5e 5 ça plus y aller
parce que ça contrôle aussi la classe de
4 vous pouvez y aura pas de tours 4
voilà donc la prise après sur vous
prendre
ouais y'a jamais des fois tu lis
malheureusement ou là donc la madame est
en l'air fou mais julie six postes
assure sûr d'un point dé 4 ok ce qui est
blanc peuvent fairisme gendarmes rang
des quatre devaient y avoir des cas
légers 6 suivi de kayes prend 1,7 et
jacques
ça peut-être
c'est compliqué pour les noirs qui
s'auto ait le temps qui me reste
je pense que bill bibi sarah va gagner
ce match ça se présente mal pour remplir
donc le clan des 4es et attaquer mais
c'est facile de le défendre comme elle
l'a fait il y aura des fous et sont
peut-être ou alors ouais surtout faut
être un bon c'est bien tout faux pas est
changée si on échange ça sera terrible
club animaux venus en descente
donc la tour rentrer au pays a besoin
well as le fouet le pion été attaquée
non cas veuillez prendre il ya des
petites nanas saito prend 1,3 mais bon
là les blancs ont réussi à l'empêcher
avec la course limite donc avec deux
pieds en plus il sait ça devrait être
alors il ya juste à emmener le roi pour
voir des trois pousser les pions et
c'est assez poussiéreux carte même
mettre le cas l'immense écart d'autres
bons f3 qu'on me la jouer pour ces 4
donc dit moi aussi ça bug lahure parce
que j'ai l'impression que ça que mon
internet n'est pas super mais voilà donc
bibi sarr a gagné et le score est
maintenant de 6 4 en la faveur 2010 à
donc dites moi si ça veuille ou pas mais
aussi ses revenus ou si ça marche mais
est ce que j'ai la pression ça date un
peu mais bon
waouh il arrive il a réfléchi groupe
officie à l'affiché de 15 secondes au
troisième coussin pub mais bon je pense
qu'elle voulait faire un truc du genre
qu'avec trois peut-être donc c'est pour
ça qu'il a réfléchi si longtemps donc à
chaque échange de ligne bibi ça va j'ai
l'impression donc c'est assez bien à sa
bulle vraiment bien prévoir et profond
donc ça c'est le début donc elle peut
être commandée café après fin d'exercice
ou alors ou alors il n'y a pas trop
d'idées à part ça en fait oui il faut g4
par exemple après peut-être qu'à veiller
à 6 la villa mais bon je dis il me
semble qu'il devrait sûrement prendre en
d4
ouais donc à ce moment là vu que la
poussière des cinq sets qui aura des
idées comme ça mais ça sera assez
facilement stoppé le prendre part à
quatre
donc là peut-être peut-être cas et j'ai
cinq ans fait pour attaquer qu on s y
soit et c'est ce qu'elle a besoin ok
surprise on reprend et après le curieux
aussi c'est quand même attaqué la dame
et où je défends la poussée f4 peut-être
voilà donc là le plomb est aussi c'est
bien faible il y aura des tours eurin
peut-être pour attaquer sûr mais je
pense qu'elles arrivent elles à réussir
à se défendre parce que bon on a pris ça
vais pas arriver il faut donc à près
d'un pont l'échangé d'un c'est pas top
qu'elle prend ainsi sur un des cas
validé quatre
surtout que le cahier pourra pas
reprendre à cause de tout reprendre à
zéro
donc ça a l'air assez dangereux je pense
que la liban devrait absolument pas
prendre part à 6
donc là peut-être que dans le futur il
ya d'ailleurs des cas il y 5 pour
laisser venir de venir à et de taper sur
l'option pour le mans il ya le cas ayant
des cartes pour ça va trop possible mais
si jamais lequel il bouge ça pourrait
être pour aller tromper zidane helmand
mais bon c'est pas si simple de mettre
la pression sur ce plan parce que le
cailly des vents très bien ça qu'il faut
faire défaut le 3 plein pour taper sur
ce cavalier mais je pense qu'à chaque
fois il poids il faut à bouger surtout
quand vous en foutez 3 en empêche
cependant on attaque iosis du court en
bloc la dois donc e52 e55 par m plus
bizarre ce coup parce que le pion était
beaucoup plus faible en ce sens qu'il
était en v6 ce sera plus facile
maintenant de l'attaqué surtout que ça
donne la classe des ce1 comble non donc
là je trouve que c'est la cible produits
blancs donc la b3 bien sûr pour défendre
ces quatre très important
mais bon c'est pas si clair de continuer
à faire du tout d'ailleurs testeur df4
mais m'en être quatre ouais ouais d'un
médecin par exemple tour en quatre mois
tout rond il ya caillaissé 2 je pense
que là où la lola web 1 le dit non que
je sais pas je ne sais pas ce qu on dire
de cette pollution
ouais je dirais que c'est quand même
gros avantage pour les noirs ou même si
c'est pas facile de passer parce que là
les blancs arrive quand même à bien
tenir même avec des tours à quatre ça
devrait attaquer pioncer cas ça devrait
gagner pour les noirs ainsi facilement x
x chier c'est aussi peut-être tour à 3
maintenant c'est possible qu'ils
attaquent le fou et la trouée et de le
client de jeu 3 c'est pas c'est pas top
france adot mon pc lui
le pauvre il a du mal avec avec le
stream sera sur twitter et youtube en
même temps je pense que ça l'a fait sur
surchauffe et un peu notamment
j'espère qu'il va tenir le coup leemon
jusqu'à l'est figé
j'espère que ça va dites-moi si sa
banane chat
ouais bon là il y aura dix troupes range
étroit plus tard bien sûr pas maintenant
parce que le foyer quand même attaqué ou
la veilleuse sa radinerie grosses
menaces ont constaté des foules détour
achète les enseignants c'est fou ça
c'est fou que peu comme qui excepté
alors qu'ils étaient la veille quant aux
avantages matériels
ça ne vient pas de moi mais du stream je
pense que ça doit être ça doit être mon
ordi qui fait le bruyant parce que je
les entends aussi flammes
donc je crois que ça vient de mon ordi à
l'image est figé hockey est ce qu'elle
est toujours figé j'espère que la clc
régler ce problème
dites moi si c'est aussi cette si c'est
par ici c'est toujours pareil on sait
pas quoi faire dans ce cas là vous qui
vous voyez pas ça pas trop l'intérêt
bon on mâche léger aucun
j'essaie de continuer encore un peu et
si ça marche pas alors du coup j'arrête
l'escrimé je reviendrai mais seulement
faisant surtout il se fait pas sur
youtube sa salade rsa sera un peu plus
en plus moins lourd pour l'ordre donc là
il dit ce qu' il reste 13 minutes et 48
secondes
donc après ça il y aura encore une pause
pendant que c'est comme ça vous pouvez
le voir sur l'écran c'est écrit sur le
times en tout temps
enfin oui clairement pas oui s'avancer
en vieux pc me plaît beaucoup
d'habitude ça va mais apparemment les
stream il n'aime pas trop
ok donc la tête pousser le 4 plus tard
ça serait la menace même de faire
décaler d'âge 3 à 4 4 mais bon j'imagine
que ça sera plutôt focalisés sur poussé
le 4s faire tourner deux tours veut en
daim bouger et pouces et peut être aussi
des défauts siens pour pour défendre le
pion donc là si on fait le cas tout de
suite après sa poussée des cinqs a pas
trop de sens du tout parce que dans le
pire des cas on aurait pu pousser
devions donc ils ont continué l'idée
comme ça bibi sahara à consommer donc
j'imagine est repoussé ce que je pense
qu'elle réussira à le faire parce que
mon n'auront pas assez les pièces pour
le dfae facilement possible sur klb
trois pattes ceci notamment celles où
alors même mais man et 4,4
à l'ecam des jeux sont figés au québec
alors je vais essayer de régler ça bon
ça devrait être réglé maintenant
parfois elles sont tellement focalisés
qu'on dirait que ce sujet mais sont
vraiment c'est juste des statues
humaines c'était tellement ils sont
elles sont dans les partis il n'y a pas
de française n'y a pas de français donc
y avait il y avait eu je sais enfin
beaucoup de joueuses qui étaient invités
donc pour moi et en plus de ça il y
avait huit joueuses qui étaient qui
auront réussi à se qualifier grâce aux
qualificatifs
donc il y avait huit tournois en fait il
y avait des traumas de 3.025 +2 je crois
et d'une minute
il y en avait plein en fait j'en avais
8es du coup grâce à ça il ya eu huit
joueuses qui ont réussi à se qualifier
et qui y participent à l'événement
maintenant et je crois que l'une d'entre
elles était peut-être me bizarre je
crois que ça devait être vallée voilà on
voit pas différent la différence entre
le feu de camp le stream bug quand c'est
pour elles réfléchissent
donc là je pense qu'il ya quelques beaux
avantages pour les blancs ça doit être
faussés ans eh bien c'est une bonne
décision pour emmener le fou là et bien
sûr sûr qu'elle ait pensé en ça avance
beaucoup parce qu'on va reprendre et
après on a raté des petites villes des
petites idées sur le yen gagne donc ça
nous arrange beaucoup ne plus leur bord
cette épine vous disons qu'il cavaliers
b3 donc mais bon là je pense qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de meilleur ou sf4 ça doit
être le seul autre coup parce que
fallait vraiment empêcher ce fou g5 donc
la recette failli dans de telles que
vous remettre le cabilat et leur mini
ranger 4 maintenant qu'il ya une case de
livres lus cloclo on ne défend plus la
cage des quatre programmes non mais ça
prend du temps et c'est pas top
c'est peut-être même sacrifié sans
lesquels ce même le kabyle b3 disons
avec dame b en emmener la tour ici c'est
de sacrifier mes pensées les blancs sont
obligés de faire ça c'est que il ya eu
des problèmes c'est pas vraiment du rêve
donc là elle réfléchit hockey à jouer
1,4 donc et veut passer la dame on a
deux et après on est fou et donc et de
vue qu'elle aimait tant le fou ne peut
plus passer angers 5
il passe de ce côté là donc c'est une
bonne leçon bonne idée merci pour le
pour les soldes aliaga
merci de la part de celle d'octobre la
fabrique du tournoi je pense que ça
devait être fouillé voyage ou le tournoi
et ses clients la meilleure offre du
monde meilleur et des pelles à beaucoup
de points elo de puisque la deuxième
donc c'est fouillis femme et après je
sais pas je pense que c'est le fpi ou en
outre après ça elles sont toutes à peu
près très forte mais à peu près dans le
même le même groupe dix ans belo ya
juste oui enfin qu' au dessus du lot
ou la nuit en sacrifice quand il se
battait aux anneaux la page
j'ai voulu les couilles du coup il s'est
passé quoi la tranquille ça c'est normal
donc là le cas et le pion à 4km à
seattle
donc elle essaye de passer le cavalier
pour ici de peut être attaqué ou là ou
là là quelle belle tactique bien vu
parce qu'il n'ya pas la dame prend à
cause de d'un pont après y aura le match
s'emballe match mais bon à part
l'allemagne est là les bons seront
obligés de perdre le cavalier donc cette
fois c'est pas top donc bien vu de la
part de qui
surtout avec une minute elle a bien
réussi à sauver sa
ouais ouais ouais si non je pense que ça
sera victoire du côté de woking mais
avec deux secondes à la pendule ça sera
assez bas poussé les deux bien sûr est
là elle menace matt donc l'aura qu'a
payé 2 je pense et après bas et va
pousser b2 n'y a pas tout simplement
gagner s'il perd pas autant bien sûr où
la cave est un roman qu'est ce que vient
de faire au nom au moins ça lol ok moi
je retire ce que j'ai dit alors parce
que vous qu'elle joue il faut en fait à
larache
ouais ça va être compliqué mais au moins
ça pour elle ayew est papa de la dame
ouais voilà c'est pas top bon bien sûr
il peut encore faire des feux encore
essayé mais bon vu près à ce qu'elle
avait à mon sens plus difficile c'est en
tout cas il y avait donc des cinq
dommage dommage dommage
j'y croyais vraiment non plus parce
qu'elle était vraiment si proche de la
victoire
ok non
bibi ça va c'était demi contre quatre et
demi je pense qu'on a on sait déjà qui
sera la main que donc il dayori restos
sont utiles et 34 secondes avant la
pause
donc après cette partie ça sera déjà
l'heure de la pause
donc elle joue toujours les mêmes le
même genre de position à chaque fois
c'est assez marrant d'ailleurs n'a pas
trop de nouveautés
elles jouent jamais et des cadres au
finder train de jouer qu'à la joue
toujours des positions un peu fermé ou
alors comme ils disent des gros centres
pour une des personnes
c'est assez marrant de voir les
militants des thèmes qui se répète
surtout avec les fouilles il ya beaucoup
de fous en diagonale enfin rempli en
cadeau
surtout j'ai l'impression que c'est
quasiment la même quel que fût qu'avant
mais avec l'option qui était un acide
qu'elle a ensuite poussé ans le centre
en tout cas ça me rappelle un peu mais
bon je pense que le gel d'un mettant un
peu différente dans cette partie là pour
ça
ça ressemble chaque fois et trois mois
mais trois y aura cavalli h5 et le fonds
sera très fort et le cas mais surtout
soir a perdu donc mais trois très grosse
heure cause de ça donc bon on dirait
qu'elle est qu'il faut qu'elle donne une
option peut-être faire un coup comme
cavalier ce qu'avait lieu le 4 ou être
mieux qu'à a troqué ses biens pour
attaquer ce pion c5
parce que même sur cahier fond dans ce
cas efficace et pas contre ibrahim parce
qu'il y aura foule pendant ces 5
donc ça a l'air d'aller quoi qu'il
arrive
demain ça va tel que faut qu'ils
arrêtent avec jour a vu que je revienne
sans entendu tout parce que si ça va lag
alors ça pas trop de sens vraiment du
coup je ne sais pas trop quoi faire
parce qu'aussi ja si j'arrête ça me
mettrait un peu de temps pour revenir en
club parce qu'il est parti ce qu'ont
déjà fini mais du coup ça sera la pause
bientôt je crois que ce il y aurait une
pelouse peu dans quatre minutes donc à
ce moment-là peut-être que je peux
arrêter et c'est de revenir mais bon
j'ai pas trop envie d'arrêter lestrille
ont donc dites moi si c'est vraiment
nécessaire d'arrêter le stream et après
de revenir
dites le moi et youku d'or j'essaierai
de la faire parce que du coup là le truc
c'est que je fais le stream a même temps
sur twitter et sur youtube et donc ça
apprend à l'enfant une tonne de co2
d'énergie dix ans de l'ordre donc voilà
donc si je fais sans que tout si je vais
juste avec toi tu peux être que ça sera
un peu plus facile
donc on peut dire que je vais essayer de
faire ça donc dites le moi si ça vaut le
coup
voilà donc laquelle si ça a pas trop de
sens parce que ce rouage suite
bien sûr il peut pas prendre là elle ne
peut pas prendre un tour parce que il y
aura d'un premier centre
donc après callas 6 pour achever le
cailly sera juste le client m6 il fera
pas grand chose sera obligé de faire des
trucs du genre tout re envers à ce
moment là la tour que ainsi passion au
bout j'ai donc c'est pas une très grosse
menace où ils échangent dom s'alarme
bizarre je suis pas sûr qu'il ait fait
le bon choix
on a surtout que la prison n'est noir a
l'air pas mal
mettons que ça peut allier celle défense
option avec après les elle pousse
suivant et que ça peut aller
s'il fait des cas et c5 aussi peut-être
surtout cette vue elle plus ferrat aimer
être 400 marches rabat sur 24 et les
plombs ce contrat offre donc quel objet
de faire des trucs du genre ça et après
essayer de bloquer ceux qui ont du style
f3 et après on est là tout un mur
ok donc à la pause je jette indre et je
reviendrai à yopougon voilà il faudra
juste que vous vous retrouviez le stream
ou alors que je vous que vous resterez
vous restiez là en attendant que je
reviens nous je vais essayer d'être
rapide mais je voulais resserrer
nécessaire commence
ok ok je pressens youtube au hockey amh
ses fruits ok donc c'est bizarre alors
c'est bizarre alors si certains
s'échinent si pour certaines personnes
ça va pour nous ça va pas oui fictive
dubitatif on dit si on veut laisser
devrait en effet j'avoue j'avoue qui du
coup j'essaie de régler ça à la pause il
vaut mieux bien voilà la position de
leur salaire n'est trop pas si mal ça a
l'air d'être au moins mieux le pas sur
la haine des blancs des beurs menace du
coup là c'est leur bien et qu'elle
essaie de défendre ce pion ça devrait
aller
même tour 3 c'est intéressant ce surtout
reprend il y avait il y avait la reprise
je pense que les normes sont pas
magnifique a dit ouais je à 5 c'était
importante justement j'allais dire parce
que faut vraiment éviter la poussée et
la poussive et 4 et maintenant qu'elle
appelle ça une devrait pas y avoir de
souci
alors qu'elle mieux 5 j'allais dire mais
peut-être que la pluie ça arrange un peu
les blancs ici et après mes torts en d3
et peut-être faire et la tour en nous la
tourelle sykes et surtout que la dépense
qui est une seconde
ça ne sera pas facile voilà ok c'est
passionnant mais bon niveau position ça
va que pour vivre sur donc là il va
gagner plus en d4
sirois et saint riquier à tour quatre
échecs après le roi les chasser il y
aura tout pour d4
voilà donc et joue bien on dit je viens
et se bat bien où là je pense qu'elle
arrête ouais ouais
oui j'allais dire que si elle prendre
des quatre maintenant liorac avis il y
aura voix moi j'ai quatre et ça m'a pas
les mêmes en est là elle a bien fait
pousser les filles ont d'abord ça c'est
une très bonne idée et après tout ce
qu'elle pousse pousse et après
maintenant elle peut prendre le cap à la
tour ouais je suis fait juste de pousser
les pions emmené à son endroit et ça
sera facilement gagné
ouais mais courant c'est cette c'est
fini canadien
donc donc c'est le score pour le monde
c'est cette cet ennemi pour bibi ça
raconte cinq ennemis pour femmes donc
ouais l'avantagé qu'a clairement pour
baby ça va quand même mais enfin pu se
doit bien
donc du coup comme j'ai dit je vais je
vais être obligé d'arrêter
malheureusement et je reviendrai sur sur
twizz seulement et j'arrêterai le
youtube et je reviendrai sa main surtout
issus de coups
donc pour ceux qui nous regardent sur
youtube vous pouvez venir c'est un truc
parce que du coup c'est impossible à
suivre donc
bon rester là et je serai de retour très
bientôt